talented brilliant incredible amazing
show-stopping spectacular
never the same totally unique completely
not ever done before
unafraid to reference or not reference
put it in a blender [ __ ] on it vomit on
it eat it and give birth to it
that's stephanie joanne angelina
germanada in a nutshell the singer
artist performer actor writer activist
pop queen and queer icon
is beloved by many and known by all as
lady gaga
by gaga has found a particularly large
fan base within the queer community
to understand the community's obsession
with lady gaga we need to travel back
down a long
rainbow timeline some of lady gaga's
critics have said her homages to pop
culture history are unoriginal
and have even accused her of ripping off
other artists madonna herself
once called lady gaga's work reductive
but when viewed through a queer lens
gaga is not a con
artist but a drag queen in her own right
drag has long been a part of the queer
and trans community particularly the
black community
in the late 1800s william dorsey swann a
former slave was the first
self-proclaimed queen
of drag swan hosted drag balls into
political action
also a first to protect the community
according to writer
brianal flynn drag today is about
borrowing cultural references to
construct a persona
many drag queens take inspiration from
and impersonate beloved icons flynn
states she borrowed tropes to construct
a persona that had cured her fame
figuratively lip singing along to the
legacies of cher madonna and the stars
she imitated
she invented gaga in the same way that
drag queen through their own alter egos
gaga is not the first pop star to
utilize drag fundamentals
to cultivate and reinvigorate her career
for instance
take cher or janet jackson or even
madonna these women have constantly
reinvented themselves decade after
decade drawing on cultural inspiration
to do so additionally
performances of exaggerated femininity
like those of sharon gaga border on that
of dragged performance according to the
professor
dr catherine horn let's not forget
gaga's avert drag performance at the
2011 vmas where she appeared as joe
caldrone gaga's lover and it performs as
joe
lasting the entire evening gaga makes
many statements on masculinity she
begins a performance with a monologue in
which joe
laminates his relationship with gaga
stating i wanted to be real
but she says joe i'm not real i'm
theater
you and i this is just rehearsal during
a backstage interview with
joe confusion amongst the journalists
can be heard while joe continues
viewing hyper masculine answers in this
performance gaga critiques not only on
masculinity but gender as a whole
pointing out it's theatrical nature
including the sexualization and
objectification of herself gaga by
herself joe that guy's been open about
her appreciation of drag and the way
that she utilizes it in her life in the
2018 film of star is born ghada's
character ally first performs
as a part of a dragonite amongst
real-life drag queens of which at least
one
shangela was specifically requested by
gaga ali does her own
pseudo-drag while she bolts out la vie
and rose
her use of drag has a profound impact on
her audience
as flynn states every person needs
references to inform their social
performance
to do a sort of drag in their daily
lives
she taught a new generation of young
people
how to drag up an identity out of a
barrenness
around them by looking to history and
pop culture
the drag queens have often been compared
to the divas of the opera and at the
heart of the connectionist camp
something that's begun to cross over
from the queer community and into the
mainstream
so much show that in the 2019 met gala
theme was camp
no ton fashion co-chaired by lady gaga
and as pointed out by lena waif's outfit
at the gala
black drag queens invented camp but
defining the word camp
remains easier said than done one option
is a style or mode of personal or
creative expression that is absurdly
exaggerated
and often fuses elements of high and
popular culture
or in a word are pop i mean
lady gaga gaga comes from a long line of
divas beloved by the gay community one
of the earliest gay icons in the modern
era is judy garland who rocketed to fame
in the wizard of oz in 1939.
she became so iconic in the queer
community that the term friend of
dorothy became slang for being gay
following her would eventually be her
own daughter liza minnelli along with
many other musical icons like barbara
streisand
donna summers grace jones brett midler
donnie parton
tina turner madonna whitney houston cher
diana ross janet jackson miranda carey
britney street christina aguilera
beyonce
and the list goes on according to
psychotherapist show court
there are several theories for the
connection between pop stars and in
particular gay men
ranging from gay men living vicariously
through the glamorous and resilient
starlet
basking in male intention to acting as a
mother figure to men whose real mothers
left something to be desired or
to starting as an escape from the
pressures of masculinity placed on boys
of all sexual identities that blossoms
into a lifelong attachment where
straight men
might place those feelings into romantic
partners gay men have mariah
and while lady gaga may serve as any all
or none of those who are fans for many
she holds an almost religious space in
their lives with many stating
that she saved them but maybe our love
for our mother monster
isn't rooted in opera camp or drag
perhaps her adoration stems from her
unabashed
love and support for us after all she's
been an out and proud by woman since the
beginning of her career
when she confirmed her queer identity
during a 2009 national interview
it was seen as momentous for some she's
since spoken on biracial within the
community
and hinted at her own feelings of not
belonging in the very community she
works hard to uplift
she's spoken of creating space for her
fans i guess what i'm trying to say
is i want to liberate them i want to
free them of their fears
and make them feel like they can create
their own space in the world
she's gone on to speak about lgbtq
rights
do charitable work including the
creation of her own foundation
the born this way foundation to help and
bullying and provide support to lgbtq
youth
and even created a physical space for
her fans during her boring this white
ball
and the born brave bus to connect and
share their experiences
not to mention her music which often
celebrates individuality queerness and
self-love
most notably her song born this way
which was partially inspired by queer
music history and became a near-instant
lgbt anthem however the song was not met
with universal approval within the
community
many felt it parented the queer
audiences the song was chosen for us
as an anthem as opposed to us finding on
our own
and others noted that gaga profiting off
of a song intended to uplift us and
essentially commercializing the
community did not sit well with them
despite these
criticisms the song has been blared in
many queer spaces for the last decade
but it is the acceptance and celebration
she created within all her music and
persona that not only creates a safe
space for queer people but also
challenges and queers the
heteronormative culture
of pop music while lady gaga is
certainly not the first pop icon
idolized by the queer community and will
definitely not be the last
the worship of divas and camp will
always be a part of the queer
community's dna
as it has been for years gaga's impact
on the youth of the 21st century
will be long-lasting and will be dancing
to her botswell into the 22nd century
or at least while the world's
[Music]
foreign